our subject for tonight how to read
your boyfriend's mind or how to read
your girlfriend's mind or your mother's mind or
your boss's mind god's mind how to read the mind
are you ready for the message all right just sort
of double check there is a popular conception
belief idea that we don't know what's going
on in people's minds and that's not true
if that were the case all psychoanalysts
would have to close up shop
and find some other line of work the
bible tells god's people how to know
what's going on in a person's mind now
it may not be with microscopic accuracy
but it will be with a certain degree of
reliability that will permit you to form and shape
a proper christian response to what you have
detected in someone's mind it is god's will
and desire that his people not go
through this world blind they must know
what is on the mind particularly of the enemy
the way god has arranged this
is found in matthew chapter 12 all right i
can preach until a certain time if i like
i will not tell you what that time
is matthew 12 reading from verse 33
and i'm using for public reading the king james
version the bible says either make the tree good
and his fruit good or else make the tree corrupt
and his fruit corrupt for the tree is known
how by his fruit now this is a biblical principle
the tree is known by his fruit you see the fruit
comes out of the tree and by looking at the fruit
you can now retrace the steps of the fruit and
come to an accurate conclusion of the source of
that fruit the tree is known by the fruit verse 34
a generation of vipers how can he that are evil
speak good things for out of the what abundance
of the what the heart what is the heart the mind
the bible says out of the abundance of the heart
what happens the mouth speaketh it is impossible
for a man or a woman to speak for a length of time
and not reveal or betray what is in the
heart god has laid down that principle
what is in the heart has to come out if
that person speaks or if that person acts
i believe that's why geld give us two of these
one of these two of these one
of these with these we listen
with these we observe you see my favorite writer
says words and actions reveal thoughts and
motives let me repeat that words and actions
reveal thoughts and motives that area of a
person normally felt to be out of bounds to the
outsider but the bible has given us a highway
to the secret of the thoughts and the motives
and that highway is paved in words and actions
how to read minds
when god gave the ten commandments from
sinai exodus chapter 20 he gave ten
let's look at number six commandment number
six it simply says thou shalt not what kill
if i were to ask and i will not ask how many of us
here have ever killed someone no hands would go up
if i were to ask all murderers raise
their hands not a hand would go up
but do you know that killing is much
more than cutting someone's head off
based on god's standard of right and wrong god's
standard is the inward condition of a man's heart
the bible is very clear you have heard that
it has been said of all time thou shalt not
kill but i say unto you that whosoever
is angry with his brother without a cause
shall be guilty of the judgment
you have heard that it hath been said by them
of all time thou shalt not kill and whosoever
shall kill shall be in danger of the judgment
but i say unto you this is jesus and when he
speaks he speaks authoritatively i say unto you
that whosoever is angry with his brother without
a cause shall be guilty of the judgment and
whosoever shall say to his brother raqqa shall be
guilty of the council and whosoever shall say it
is brother thou fool shall be guilty of hell fire
what is jesus saying there is more to murder
than the physical cessation of
someone's life by some external force
when by unreasonable fits
of anger by attacking people
we reduce the quality of their lives
the bible regards that as murder
the person can be fully alive but
if he or she suffers a reduction in
the quality of life god calls that murder
it's murder that takes place in the heart
so what we have is the outward expression of thou
shalt not kill and none of us is guilty of the
outward expression then jesus came on mount the
sermon on the mount and shocked his listeners by
saying it is possible to commit murder in the
heart in the heart now the law of california
puts you in prison or sends you the electric
chair if you commit murder physically
the law of california will not lay a finger
on you if you kill someone in your heart
are you following me this state this country
will inflict no punishment on anyone who commits
murder in the heart there is no law against
being angry there is no law against resentment
there is no law against jealousy there is no
law against praying for someone to drop dead
there are no laws against that kind of internal
behavior but god has some strict laws against it
which then must compel us to pause and reflect
that there is more to the quality of
one's moral life than what one does
even the law of the land goes beyond behavior
and tries to assess the mind we said earlier
today there's something in law called malice
if you commit a crime and malice can be proved if
you can if you commit a crime and motive can be
proved lawyers are always looking for what is the
motive if there's no motive then there's no crime
the case is weak if you cannot uncover a
motive is there some large insurance settlement
was he about to be exposed for something he did in
some concentration camp is there a motive without
a motive the case is weak now motive is not
something physical motive is something from within
and the law of the land seeks out motive it
seeks to examine it casts a legal searchlight
on the heart looking for motive looking
for malice looking for premeditation
now if the law of the land can
do that what about god's law
let me tell you something about god
almost five minutes after eight
god is a god of procedure and process
and chronology what do i mean simple
example first john chapter one verse
nine you know it if we confess our sins
he is what fifa just said with me to for
give us our sins and to cleanse us from
all unrighteousness there is a step-by-step
process in that verse what comes first confess
then what forgiveness and cleansing
let's look at how this functions in nature mark
428 for the earth bringing forth fruit of herself
first the blade then what the ear then what after
that the full corn in the ear there is a step
by step principle that functions in the spiritual
world it functions in the natural world one thing
must happen before something else happens
god is a god of step by step procedures
if that weren't the case we could not
depend on prophecy are you following me
we are a prophetic people and we say in 457 bc our
xerxes released the captives to go back and build
the walls of jerusalem and we say in 431
jesus christ was crucified we say in 434
stephen was turned and we have it notched and
marked on chronological charge one thing at a
time and if something's not in place someone
will jump up and cause a spiritual ruckus we
believe that prophecy requires that things happen
according to their place in a sequence of events
you know that's the way it is with sin
sin follows a sequence of events god is aware of
that and he has made the appropriate resources
available to us now here is the step-by-step
process of sin and we must understand as we
continue with the subject how to read
minds bible says in james chapter 1
reading from verse 13 let no man say when he's
tempted i am tempted of god for god cannot be
tempted with evil neither tempteth he any man
now but every man is tempted when he's what
drawn away of his own lust and
entice that's step number one
then when lust has conceived it does
what bring it forth sin step number two
and sin when it is finished if not confessed
bring it forth what death step number three
it is essential to understand this process in
sinning for us to understand what i'm about to say
let me repeat sin does not occur
haphazardly
sin does not occur haphazardly it is procedural
it begins in the mind where
the lusts of the flesh reside
the unconverted mind the unregenerate mind the
mind described in romans 8 7 because the carnal
mind is enmity against god for it is not subject
to the law of god neither indeed can be that mind
now god has a remedy for sin
and the remedy has always been his righteousness
now if sin has a process step by step
the lust the conceiving the bringing
forth of death where do you believe
that god has to place his
remedy at which step step one
step one the mind the breeding
ground of the lusts the mind now
let's go to jeremiah chapter 31 we shall read
verse 33 as we continue how to read minds
jeremiah 31 reading verse 33 keep in
mind sin is a step-by-step process
it's not haphazard it is procedural it is
a process and in recognizing that process
god applies the remedy with that process
in mind but this is the covenant which i
shall make with them with the house of israel
after those they save the lord i will do what
put my law where in the inward part and they'll
do what write it where in their hearts and will
be their god and they shall be my people
now god is saying i will put the remedy
right at the source right at the origin right at
the headwaters of the river of unrighteousness
i will put my law
in their hearts in the inward parts
in the mind wherever sin originates
that's where i will put my
law so at the very microsecond
that sin begins to stir at the level
of the thought the law shines on that
so god writes his law on our hearts because that
is where it begins and that is where it should end
what do i mean by that it should end many of us
we have a struggle with sin at level number two
then when lusts have conceived it bringing
forth sin and that's a little late some of us
we don't realize we have a struggle we'll only
realize it when step three is inflicted upon
us then sin when it is finished bringing
forth death and then there's no hope
but we must deal with sin at the level
of the beginning at the point of origin
at the point of departure and that is the mind and
this is where god places the counteracting force
which is his law
the standard of righteousness by
which he judged the angels that fell
by which he judged that tremendous being that
jesus christ created lucifer when he said he
violated that law god writes that on our hearts
now you say but preacher how does he do that
let me tell you how god writes it on the
heart at our invitation come on say amen
it is at our invitation
in exodus chapter 31 verse 18 exodus 31 verse 18
the bible says and when he had made an end
of communion with moses upon mount sinai
he gave unto him two tables
of testimony tables of stone
finish that verse for me written
with the finger of god pause
am i to understand that god the father came
down and actually wrote with his finger am i to
understand that jesus christ who was actually the
member of the godhead who came down on sinai whose
voice shook the earth according to hebrews
12 and scribbled it with his fingernail no
what is the writing agent of god all right someone
said the holy spirit and someone spoke correctly
but let's demonstrate that biblically the finger
of god that's how he wrote the commandments
let's go to exodus chapter eight let's read verses
18 and 19. as we continue how to read minds and i
hope you're praying that the spirit of god will
touch hearts even as i speak and that god spirit
will give me the right words because it is a very
delicate sensitive and absolutely crucial subject
exodus 8 verses 18 and 19 this is the third
plague the plague of lies egypt have suffered
the plague of blood they have suffered the
plague of frogs now god sends the plague
of lies by the way it was not necessary for egypt
to suffer ten plagues one should have been enough
and it's quite possible there are egyptians
listening to me now god has sent one plague
in your life to wake you up but you're tough
one player can't do it you're too tough
so he has to send another one but you're
a marine so you need three and four
let me tell you something when you
push god god will break your back
you ask pharaoh when you push god god will
break your back god will kill you if he sent
a plague you tell him real quick lord one is
enough thank you i've got the point this is our
theme for this restoration i've got the point no
more plagues and so the third play came on egypt
and when aaron threw the dust in the air there was
lice on beast and man the bible says in verse 18
and verse 19 and the egyptian magicians did so
with the enchantment to bring forth lies verse
9 verse 18 and they could not so there was lies
on man and beast now verse 19. then the egyptian
the magician said unto pharaoh this is what the
finger of god you see they tried couldn't do it
when moses turned the waters to blood
they did something that looked like it
did you hear what i said when the
frogs were brought up at god's command
they did something that looked like it
but you can only go so far to imitate god
at some point the greatness of god leaves you
in the dust they tried to imitate the plague
of lies they couldn't and they confessed
to pharaoh this is the finger of god this
plague is the finger and we see it clearly
let's go to psalm 8. reading from verse 3
16 minutes after 8. psalm 8 reading from verse 3.
the bible says when i consider thy heavens the
works of thy fingers the moon and the stars which
thou hast ordained when i consider thy heavens
the works of thy fingers now go to psalm 104 verse
30. psalm 104 verse 30 notice david talks about
the works of his fingers the created works
psalm 104 verse 30 the bible says thou
send this forth thy spirit they are created
the spirit is the energizing force in creation
now let's go to the new testament the
finger of god we're still trying to identify
let's go to the book of matthew chapter 12.
we're looking at an incident where jesus had
cast out some demons and the pharisees always
ready to explain away divine power accuse him
of using the power of the yells above and jesus
said in matthew 12 28 but if i cast out devils
with the spirit of god then the kingdom of god
is common to you jesus said i cast out devils
with the spirit of god let's go
to luke chapter 11. same story
this time reported by luke luke chapter 11
verse 20. the same incident reported by luke
the beauty of here a little and there are luke
11 verse 20 the bible says but if i by what the
finger of god cast out devils no doubt
the kingdom of god is come upon you
if i by the finger we have the finger in luke 11
20 we have the spirit in matthew 12 28 same thing
the finger of god is the spirit of god so when the
bible says in exodus 31 verse 18 written with the
finger of god the holy spirit was the active agent
in that divine inscription of god's law now as he
was the one who wrote it on tables of stone it
is he who writes it on the tables of our hearts
second corinthians chapter three verse three
second corinthians three verse three the bible
says for as much as he had manifestly declared to
be the epistles of christ ministered by us written
not with ink but with the spirit of the living
god not on tables of stone but on fleshy tables
of the heart paul is saying that the holy spirit
has written god's will and god's law on our hearts
why on the heart not on the hand in deuteronomy
6 you don't have to turn there that's where
moses says under god's instructions here
oh israel the lord our god is one lord
thou shalt love the lord with all
thy heart i saw without thy might
then he says in the next verse and these
words which i command you this day shall be
in thine heart that's god's will in thine
heart verse 80 says and thou shalt bind them
for a sign upon thine hand and they shall be
as frontlets between their eyes now the jews
took that the wrong way they felt that if
they were to stuff a little bit of the law in
a in a leather pouch and put it here tied back of
the head and put it here then they had it in their
minds or they would put some in a little hole
outside of the door of the house or bang it around
their house or put it in the post of the house
according to verse 9 of deuteronomy 6 this wasn't
what god had in mind the sign upon the hand was to
remind them that his law should be in their hearts
the only place god's law belongs is in the heart
because when it is in the heart
it attacks sin at the origin
now i said to you this state or this country
cannot punish you for hating someone that's
not a crime but it's a sin are you with
me it's not a crime it's a sin it is quite
possible there's someone listening
to me now who resents someone else
now you don't go to jail for that but god doesn't
like it and so you're condemned in god's eyes for
that because while the state as one pioneer
wrote calls for civility god's law calls for
what morality are you listening to me
god's look and morality is not what you do
wait a minute now don't think i'm giving
you license to go say well i can do what
i like he said that's not morality listen to
what i mean morality is a matter of the heart
god's procedure as i said is if the
heart is right the behavior will be right
is there someone here who does not understand that
have you ever heard someone
say his heart is not in it
and it's not a spiritual statement but
we somehow realize we understand we sense
it's almost instinctive almost reflexive you've
got to put something in it that's not physical
i don't see that your heart is in it
i was watching a documentary on training
for the seals and i'm told that the seals
training is designed to expose weakness
what is the weakness it's in the mind
but they're seeking because they know if the
weakness remains in the mind it will endanger
the mission they're seeking to expose what is in
the mind the world does that god's law does it
now 22 after eight i have about 15 minutes
god's law is a moral law no christian
disagrees with that because god is
a moral god listen to me closely
how many commandments are there 10
which one do you have to break
to be declared an immoral person
number seven thou shalt not commit
adultery no one argues with that
an adulterer is immoral am i right yes six
thou shalt not kill a murderer is immoral
but you're more immoral for adultery than murder
thou shalt not bear false witness a liar is
seen as the son is not necessarily immoral
what we have unconsciously done
we have divided the commandments
this is immorality and this is bad judgment
let me tell you something ecclesiastes 12 13
and 14. let us hear the conclusion of what
the whole matter fear god and do what
keep his commandments for this is what
the whole duty of man now the entire duty of
man is encompassed in god's ten commandments
and it's a moral decalogue here's what
i want you to get and don't all rush to
explain your points to me when the service
is over that's the least thing a preacher
wants a long discussion after preaching
give me time to sleep catch me tomorrow
if every aspect of our lives whole duty
is judged by a moral law listen to me
then everything we do is either what
is either moral or immoral
you don't look convinced
let me explain it this way
let me talk to the men you're
watching a football game on sunday
the quarterback throws the ball to the wide
receiver he catches it and starts to run
and the ref blows the whistle and does this
what's that traveling can the ref do that no
why not it's not a basketball game the
rules are what football and everything that
happens must be judged by what kinds of rules
football rules now if on a basketball court
someone makes a fancy pass then the opposing
player hits him in the ribs then you call the
police because that's not football where you are
legally allowed to kill someone that's basketball
now what i'm saying is in life god has
a set of rules that judge the game of
life and those rules are entirely
moral from number one to number ten
anything you and i do is properly
judged as either moral or immoral
now 25 after eight consider this how many of you
have ever broken the sabbath raise your hands
were we guilty of immorality yes or no
yes now how many immoral people are
listening to me now don't tell me
don't tell don't tell me don't tell me
how many of us have ever disrespected our parents
was that an act of immorality yes
but if someone has said to you you are immoral
you'd have said me i've never committed adultery
never killed so i am a moral person no listen
to me everything we do comes under judgment
listen to the verse again ecclesiastes 12 13 14
let us hear the conclusion of the whole matter
fear god and keep his commandments for this
is the whole duty of man for god shall bring
every work into judgment with every what
secret thing whether it be good or evil
what we do in life comes under one or two
headings good or evil there isn't a third
i don't care how creative your thinking ability is
there is not a third it's either good or it's bad
how many of us waste time
oh don't raise your hands you look too eager
that's immoral you see immorality
is that which goes against god
not that which has you consistent with
playboy or whatever else immorality is that which
goes counter to god's standard of uprightness
if we would see our lives in the
context of morality or immorality
there are many things we would not do
because half decent people tend to
view immorality as something to avoid
tomorrow i'm preaching on health
you know health is a matter of a moral necessity
let me say that again god requires god has a
moral requirement that we protect our health
you don't pursue some gym just to get into a size
26 dress you do it because it's morally correct
it is required of god's decalogue under
the sixth commandment thou shalt not kill
so what i'm saying is god is trying by the
indwelling power of his holy
spirit to develop a moral people
and when we understand that it affects everything
we do every department of our lives and the power
to do it is the holy spirit within us and the
light of the law casting its light on everything
that we do and we see it to be wrong at the
level of the thought and that's where we stop it
my favorite writer says who's my favorite writer
ellen white that's right who knows nothing
about ellen white raise your hands you know
nothing about ellen white someone saved that boy
we have to get him a book messages to young people
some adventist friend get that by your book
messages to young people by monday or tomorrow
who else has never heard of ellen white raise your
hands good good good ah just one one distinguished
handsome young man messages to young people
coming up for you you don't get it by monday
come and see me when you get it read it she said
sin must be stopped at the level of the thought
at the level of the thought because once it just
begins as a thought we have not yet dwelt on it
it is not a sin for which we are charged it
is merely a sinful thought a sinful impulse
to which we have not responded other than to
say lord by your grace i say no at that level
let me tell you something that i do
when evil thoughts come into my head
do you know evil thoughts come into the heads
of preachers did you know that perhaps more
than your head particularly when the heads
of this size evil thoughts come into the head
now here's what i do i start quoting bible verses
let me tell you something as god listens to me
before i can finish the passage the thought
is gone now let me say it comes back
the devil has a work to do but we must be more
persistent than he is you see when the devil
came to jesus christ command that these stones
be made bread what did jesus say it is written
man shall not live by bread alone i'm giving
you a technique to use now jesus didn't say it
is written keep the sabbath why it didn't fit it
didn't fit any verse doesn't fit your verse must
fit the temptation the temptation was turn these
stones to bread and jesus quoted deuteronomy 8
verse 3 and that man shall not live by bread alone
it fit and the devil backed off when the devil
said cast thyself down for it is written he used
the bible too jesus said it is written thou shalt
not tempt the law thy god the devil backed off
jesus said jesus didn't say thou shall not kill
when he came with the third all this will i give
you if you fall down and worship me jesus said
it is written thou shall worship the lord thy god
and him only shalt thou serve for every temptation
jesus had a verse that fit the temptation they
tell me enzymes are shaped a certain way to fit
some receptor am i right your textual enzymes
must be properly shaped to fit that temptation
because we have to deal with sin through the power
of god's word the ten commandments are god's word
god has no other standard to
tell us what's right and wrong
this if we would ask god by the agency of his
holy spirit and under the direction of jesus
christ to write his law in our hearts ask him
you will begin to experience an opposition to sin
are those all the amens i can get
let me say that again 8 33
the time he gave me was 8 40. i didn't want to
tell you i'll tell you now we have seven minutes
if we will ask god to write his law on our
hearts by the agency of the holy spirit
under the direction of jesus christ we would
begin to experience a divine impulse a holy
recoiling from that which is wrong at the very
point of his inception and we will see to it by
the power of god and the righteousness of his
law that all sinful thoughts would be stillborn
because we must hate sin like poison if we
would spend more time hitting sin and not
hating one another we would be spiritually
advanced far beyond where we are now
my beloved brothers and sisters the
kingdom of god is established in the mind
not in uh wherever the capital of california
is whatever that is in michigan it's
lansing the kingdom of god is not established
outwardly not yet that's coming but at present
it must find a place in the mind that's where
a moral person is in the mind we are too
behaviorally focused behavior has its place but
behavior cannot deviate from its origin that is
the mind because out of the abundance of the heart
the mouth speaketh a tree is known by its fruit
and god places his law which is absolutely
anti-sin right at the point where sin
begins so that at point number one we have power
from on high because god's desire is that the
righteousness of the law might be fulfilled in us
well god says fine i'll put it right in your heart
is there no one in this place who is tired of sin
you all right how many of us are tired of sin
raise your hands you have to be tired of sin
is there no one here who wants
jesus christ to come quickly
how many of us want that can i see your hands
my brothers and my sisters i speak from my heart
this is no joke we must desire jesus christ
more than anything else under the sun
we must hate sin don't you realize the very first
promise of the bible is a promise of hate and i
will put enmity between thee and the woman between
thy seed and her seed god has promised promise
number one i'll give you some hatred it seems
unusual for god to promise hatred yes he does
but it's hatred for sin not sinners
tonight i'd like to leave this
place believing with all my heart
that my brothers and sisters who
have sat and listened have understood
that the power to overcome sin can be placed right
at the source of sin itself that's in the heart
so that while we're born with a certain nature
when we are born of the spirit then we have
an opposing force that's the spirit
and the spirit has written this the law of right
and wrong right on the mind the source of thoughts
how many of you will say lord this message
has affected me i want you to put your law
don't respond yet i want you to write your
law in my heart i want you to think before
you respond how many will say father put hatred
in my heart for sin i want your law written in
irradicably on the fleshy tables of my heart so
that i begin to do what's right naturally if any
one of you will say that with me let me see your
right hand please would you confirm it by standing
let's let god record this response we must
hate sin we must hate sin we must hate sin
it is sin that put jesus christ on the cross
it is sin that causes supervisors to mistreat
those who are under them it is sin that causes men
to put their wives in hospitals it is sin that has
people strung out on drugs it is sin that makes
hospitals necessary it is sin that causes children
to run away from home it is sin it is sin it is
sin and there is an answer that the righteousness
of jesus christ as expressed in his law
and i'm glad you're standing to say god this
is a desperate cry write your law on my heart
every head bowed every i close
father in the name of jesus
if i in any way have missed
spoken i ask for your forgiveness
the subject is so sensitive if i have
elevated myself i ask again for your pardon
father i plead with you now in the name of your
son whose blood still flows for our cleansing
that you would accept the response of your
people they have risen to say we want your law
written on our hearts by the active agency of
the holy spirit under the direction of jesus
christ lord please this is according to your
will it must be your will that your law be
written on our hearts at the very source where
sin begins write it there god inscribe it i pray
that we may be spiritual creatures loving that
which is spiritual hating everything that is
anti-god hating that which is unrighteous and
hating sin give us a perfect hatred for sin
and the love for righteousness let your law be
a living reality in our hearts that it may be
seen in our fruit because the tree is known by the
fruit father in the name of jesus hear this prayer
bless us tonight bring us back
tomorrow to hear more of your word
i offer this prayer in jesus name and for
his sake let all god's people say amen amen
you